this is a very exciting day for us
because as you all know my trusty
assistant sona mov session has been on
maternity leave she uh gave birth to
twin boys a couple of months ago and uh
she is back with us today uh so matt
gourley join me in welcoming
sona mo session back to the podcast sona
how are you hey hi hi
you did it uh first of all i have to say
um you
dropped by the other day you didn't
record but you dropped by with uh your
your husband tack and you look fantastic
and everybody was remarking on how
amazing it is you gave birth to twins
and you just uh look uh absolutely
stunning and very and you're also very
happy you seem like a very happy person
you must like these little critters i
like them a lot i love them a lot i
think they're really cool i think that
they they suck out everything that i've
got to give
[Music]
um jesus
they take
everything from me
so hold on a second that's i'm saying
that in it does it not come off in a
loving way i know it's covering all the
bases yeah it really is everything
i think that i can't gain weight because
they take everything i feel that the
same way about my representation you
know uh yeah it's just my agent my agent
and manager it's the same thing and they
literally drink from my teats oh
god come on they do and uh sorry i just
want to put that image out there
but no i so wait a minute you uh you
have these two boys
yes and you sent me pictures uh all the
time and it's because i keep my wife has
said i've never seen you this excited
about any kids including our own and
it's true
every time you send me pictures they're
uh they're hilarious little fellows yes
they are they we dress them up like
little men yes it's funny i love that
you dress them up uh they look like uh
they're two
two little men that would sell you
aluminum siding you know for your house
and so i'm really just delighted to and
it's mikey and charlie right mikey and
charlie yeah they're very sweet they're
they're two months now and then uh
they're almost three months and i look
that's how it works and guess what then
four is going to come after that oh
thanks okay zing
yeah you got me good pretty good huh wow
real good
so um
i'm sorry i'm just not gonna sit here
while she says it's two months now but
then it's gonna be three i'm not gonna
let that go well it could be the
beginning of two months or it could be
the end of two months it's right close
to the end of two months and it's almost
three months so good to have you back
sona it's great to be back conan um what
a warm welcome this is the magic is back